a campaign by a New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie to crack down on
distracted driving recently swept up a
high profile offender newly released
video shows the SUV of the Garden States
First Lady Mary Pat Christie being
pulled over last April the officer says
she was holding a phone in her hand the
distracted driving crackdown was ordered
by Governor Christie Zone Attorney
General 15 states and the District of
Columbia have already banned held held
devices while driving among them is
Washington State which is now citing
drivers for driving under the influence
of electronics Kris Van Cleave visited
Seattle to see how lawmakers hope the
stigma will lead to safer roads good
morning we're riding along with the
Washington State Patrol as they're
beginning to enforce a new law here in
Washington that's unlike anything in the
country they're calling it DUI II
driving under the influence of
electronics and the name is supposed to
get driver's attention the goal here is
to get them to put down their phone in
Washington State
the phone can cost a driver big no
matter what the reason okay you know
unfortunately that's not gonna be a
legal reason to get him out of any of
the issues he's got going on today
what's going on could now be considered
DUI driving under the influence of
electronics state trooper Rick Johnson
what about holding the phone up here
using the GPS
you can't hold the phone at all do you
think calling this law DUI II gets
people's attention I think it does the
DUI part of it catches their attention
and then they get curious about the e
the law is the first of its kind in the
US while fines start around a hundred
and thirty bucks
that cost pales in comparison to the one
Tina Meyer pays every day Cory is a kid
who was he's my baby in December of 2015
her 23 year old son Cody was working on
a road construction crew outside Seattle
the driver of this Jeep told police he
was looking at his phone and slammed
into Cody who after months in the
hospital suffered a massive heart attack
I knew Cody would never want to live
that way and so we had to make that
decision to shut the machines off and
end our son's life and all because
somebody had to pick up a cell phone and
look at it you are just as dangerous or
more so when you are on a cell phone
than a drunk drivers Washington governor
jay Inslee actually vetoed a provision
in the law that would have delayed its
implementation a year he wanted it in
effect now we're gonna reduce drunk
electronic driving and that's what this
is it's part of that then trying to
create a stigma with texting and driving
with being on your cell phone one of the
successful things why we've reduced
drunk driving it has become a great
stigma the bill was not without
controversy critics complained that
being able to pull someone over simply
for holding their cell phone was a
little too aggressive the warning period
ends in January and then those increased
fines become a reality for drivers Kris
Van Cleave CBS News see ya
please put down your cell phones
hopefully this will make a difference